officials declared an all-out war on
covet 19 as the number of cases
continued to steadily increase in yangon
myanmar's largest city in the country's
second wave that started in august new
infections and deaths are increasing
faster than anywhere else in the world
yangon's stay-at-home order is in its
third week
a member of the yangon kovic 19 control
committee says their hospitals are
struggling to keep
up a city of seven million it only has
hospital beds for eight thousand
19 management we have to imitate china
they controlled rouhan very
systematically to get things back after
the outbreak
that's why we have to imitate them
myanmar has one of the world's most
underfunded health care systems most
people initially seek care at fever
clinics
run by volunteers
depending on the situation we used to
refer the suspected coronavirus patients
to hospital during the first wave
until the earlier days of the second
wave but now we can't refer them to the
hospitals anymore as there's no room
critics say that the decision to push
forward with the november eighth
election in the shadow of the pandemic
favors the ruling party led by onsongsu
chi human rights groups and the main
opposition party have urged election
officials to delay the polling the
requests
were rejected the general election is
just a month away
we don't see any safety preparations as
a citizen
and a voter i'm afraid of going to the
ballot as i'm afraid of the potential
crowd
the m voter 2020 app was launched to
provide candidate information
the head of the election commission
saying it was a way to help voters amid
the covet 19 restrictions but some
rights in democracy groups have
criticized the app for its inclusion of
categories listing the candidates race
and religion and labeling rohingya
candidates as bengali
but for now in addition to the growing
concern about the safety and accuracy of
the election
the people of yangon are waiting to hear
when it's safe to go back
outside scott hadler al jazeera